نستكمل معكم مشاهدينا هذه التغطيه على
مدار الساعه والخاصه فيما يحدث بالسودان
من اشتباكات منذ اربعه ايام فعلى وقع
اطلاق النار دخلت الهدنه المعلنه حيز
التنفيذ ولكن دون التزام طرفي النزاع بها
رغم مرور ساعتين عليها الا انها لم تلقى
اذان صاغيه الاشتباكات اشتدت بمحيط مبنى
القياده العامه للقوات المسلحه في العاصمه
الخرطوم مع اتهام كل طرف للاخر بخرق
الهدنه اما الامم المتحده وواشنطن فاعلنتا
فشل الهدنه فيما يامل السودانيون ويتمنون
دقائق قليله من الهدنه لاستغلالها للوصول
الى مياه الشرب او الحصول على مواد غذائيه
[موسيقى]
وجه والي الخرطوم المكلف احمد عثمان حمزه
بعوده محطات مياه الشرب للعمل بشكل عاجل
وذلك خلال اجتماع لاداره الازمه مع
مسؤولين عن الخدمات ومديريه محليات
الولايات وطمان والي الخرطوم الى جاهزيه
محطات المياه بعد التعرض عدد منها لاعطال
جراء القصف ما تسبب بالقطاع الامداد
المائي عن الاحياء السكانيه لافتا الى ان
توفير قوات لتامين القوى العامله في صيانه
الاعطال تم تامينها وتناول الاجتماع جهود
وزاره الصحه في تامين العلاج باقسام
الطوارئ والعمل مع الجهات الامنيه لحمايه
تحركات الكوادر الطبيه وتامين وصول
الادويه الى المستشفيات
ينضم الينا مشاهدينا من الخرطوم وراس
العربيه سالم الهاشمي للحديث عن ولنقل
الصوره طبعا من على الارض ولمعرفه اذا ما
كانت هذه الهدنه ما زالت يعني بحاله الخرق
التي كنا نتابعها قبل قليل سلام كيف هو
الوضع من هناك كيف هي الصوره هل اطلاق
النار مازال مستمر
نعمل الان في الخرطوم هناك هدوء نسبي
قليلا لكن هناك مقذوفات وقعت في اكثر من
منزل في في مدينه بحري كان بعيده الافطار
وقعت مقذوفه في شرق النيل في مدينه في
مدينه بحري في الجريف شرق من امام المنزل
وادت الى وفاه ثلاثه من اسره واحده ومقذوف
اخر وقع الان في ايضا في مدينه بحري كذلك
في منطقه الصافيه وادى الى حرق منزل
بالكامل لكن ليس فيه اي اصابات
هذا اخر المستجدات هذه المقذوفات التي تقع
ولا يعرف حتى
المواطنون ولا اصحاب المنزل ولا المنازل
المجاوره من الذي كان متسببا في اندلاع
هذه النيران اضافه الى ان اطفاء هذه النار
في هذا المنزل اطفئت ولله الحمد الان
اطفئت بمجهودات شعبيه
شباب الحي وحي اخر كذلك بالقرب منهم جاء
هؤلاء الشباب
ثم بعد ذلك تحصلوا على طفايات حريق والان
اضربت هذه النيران ولله الحمد سالم يعني
بالصوره على الارض الان عمليات الاشتباك
المتقطعه التي تتحدث عنها محصوره اين
بمحيط القياده العامه بمناطق اخرى كيف هي
الصوره يعني بهذا
المجال والاطار
نعم
المكان معين لان غالب الاشتباك كان بعد
الافطار اي بعد بدايه هذه الهدنه
كان بدايه بالطائرات ومضادات الطائرات
التي كانت في سماء الخرطوم فكانت متفرقه
هذه المضادات من محيط القياده كذلك هنا في
مدينه بحري في جهه جسر شمبات وايضا في جهه
كافوري كذلك اي شرقا وغربا في هذه المناطق
نستمع الى دليل الانفجارات وايضا هذه
المضادات مضادات الطائرات
سالم يعني مضادات الطائرات الاشتباكات ما
زالت مستمره بالرغم نحن نتحدث عن حوالي
ثلاث ساعات من من توقيت او ساعتين من
توقيت دخول الهدنه الاسلحه التي تستخدم
الان يعني بهذه الدقائق ما زالت اسلحه
ثقيله ما زلنا نتحدث عن وتيره قويه
لاستخدام السلاح ام انها خفت نوعا ما عن
الساعات الاولى للهدنه
نعم هنا لابد ان يؤكد على معنى مهم جدا
وهو اولا ان هذه
الهدنه ليست
مختلفه عن الهدنه التي كانت بالامس وفي
اليوم الذي قبله هذه اللحظه
نعم تم خرق هذه الهدنه بهذه المقذوفات
وبهذا الاشتباك هذه الاشتباكات المتكرره
وهذا واضح ونراه
الان على الارض واضح جدا ان هذه
الاشتباكات متواصله لكن الان هناك هدوء
نسبي في هذه اللحظات
هذا هذا الهدوء النسبي طبعا يعني كان هناك
العديد من
التحليلات اذا صح التعبير ومن الاراء بانه
ممكن ان يكون هدوء نسبي وان ينسحب يعني ان
تكون هدنه متقطعه هل هذه الهدنه المتقطعه
ممكن ان تسمح للناس بالخروج وقضاء
حاجياتها ان كان يعني
الصحيه او الغذائيه او غيرها
هم الان الناس حريصون على ان تكون هذه
الهدنه ليست نسبيه بل تكون كليه لاجل ان
يقوموا بقضاء حاجياتهم وان تقوم كذلك
ولايه الخرطوم بالافاء بما وعدت به فيما
يتعلق بالمياه لان موضوع المياه يشكل
هاجسا الان بالنسبه للمواطنين
حقيقي بالنسبه لمواطني مدينه بحري
والمدن الثلاث كذلك كلها تاتينا الشكاوى
من انقطاع المياه وازمه المياه الموجوده
حقيقه
يتاسف كل من يقول هذه العباره في دوله يمر
بها نهر النيل او النيلين كذلك
ازمه مياه شرب
مياه
المواجهات عن ازمه صحيه وازمه خطيره يعني
على المجتمع السوداني سالم هل رصدتم اي
تحرك للقوات على الارض اتحدث عن قوات
الجيش وقوات الدعم السريع انسحاب من منطقه
الى اخرى تجميع للقوى العسكريه ام انهم ما
زالوا يعني ثابتين باماكن
الان
باستطلاعنا لشهود الاعيان هنا في مدينه
بحري تحدثوا انه قبيل الافطار اي حوالي
الساعه الخامسه والنصف الخامسه هناك كانت
تحركات لسيارات دفع رباعي تدفع للدعم
السريع كانها تقوم بعمليه تمشيط هنا في
الطريق الرابط ما بين شارع الانقاذ وشارع
المعونه كانت هذه السيارات الدفع الرباعي
تمر واثارت ذعرا ورعبا عند المواطنين
وتوجس كذلك هذا كله يفهم في السياق بعد
القرارات التي اصدرها رئيس مجلس السياده
والقائد العام للجيش السوداني باعتبار هذه
القوه قوه متمرده
يعني حل هذه القوه بالكامل كل هذا يجعل
هنالك ذعرا وتوجسا من التعامل مع قوات
الدعم السريعه او في تحركاتها في داخل
المدينه
سالم بالساعات الماضيه كان هناك ايضا
اخبار متتاليه عن
حشد ان كان لي قوات الدعم السريع وان كان
للجيش من مناطق اخرى الى الوسط الى حيث
تدور المواجهات هل يعني هذه حتى وان كانت
هدنه متقطعه هل رصدتم ايضا وصول اي قوات
من خارج الخرطوم
نعم نحن لم نرصد حقيقه هذه التحركات كذلك
لكن ما يتم رصده هي البيانات التي تصدر
كذلك لان الجيش السوداني كان قد اصدر
بيانا اكد فيه ان قوات الدعم السريع تبحث
عن هذه الهدنه من اجل ان تصل ان تصل اليها
تعزيزات عسكريه وكذلك لوجستيه هذا بحسب
الناطق الرسمي باسم الجيش السوداني في ان
الحديث عن هذه الهدنه هو من اجل هذين
الامرين يعني
تعزيزات العسكريه ودعم لهذه القوات لكن
بعد هذا التصحيح مباشره جاء تصريح عضو
مجلس السياده الفريق شمس الدين كباشي الذي
اكد فيه التزامهم بهذه الهدنه لمده 24
ساعه وكان قائد قوات الدعم السريع قد اكد
انهم ملتزمون بهذه الهدنه لكن الى الان
على الارض لم يرى المواطنون اثارا واضحه
لهذه الهدنه يعني
بالرايئه الاخر بهذا الموضوع
وبما رصدناه مع ضيوفنا من الخرط وم يقولون
بان هناك ليس هناك سيطره كامله للقيادات
على العناصر الموجودين على الارض وخصوصا
الدعم السريع هل ايضا هذه النقطه ممكن ان
تكون قد اسهمت بتاخر دخول الهدنه الكليه
ومن هنا نسمع يعني اشتباكات متقطعه وهدنه
متقطعه
وربما يكون هذا واحد من الاسباب لكن
بالنظر الى معطياتها الواقع يقول انه ربما
حتى الان تصريحات المتبادله كذلك من
القيادات قد تم في هذه النظريه كذلك بعد
تصريحات قوات الدعم السريع بان
قوات الجيش السوداني هي من بادره اختراق
هذه الهدنه ربما مثل هذه التصريحات تفهم
في سياق ان الطرفين ربما لا يملكان
الاراده الكامله لتنفيذ هذه الهدنه سالم
ابقى معي لو سمحت الزميل سالم الهاشمي
مراسل العربيه من الخرطوم ابقى معنا من
الخرطوم ايضا مشاهدينا
ينضم نور الدين بابا بكر الناطق الرسمي
باسم حزب المؤتمر السوداني والقيادي في
قوى الحريه والتغيير استاذ نور الدين كنتم
يعني
قوى مدنيه طلبتم الجهات
اتحدث هنا عن طرفي النزاع بالالتزام
بالعوده الى طاوله الحوار بالالتزام بالحل
السلمي وايضا التزام الهدنه لتجنيب
المواطنين كارثه ما يحصل ما يحصل الان بعد
دخول الهدنه حيز التنفيذ مع عدم الالتزام
الكامل بها ماذا يعني من الناحيه
الانسانيه ومن الناحيه السياسيه
طيب الرحمه والمغفره للثلاثه المدنيين
الذين سقطوا جراء الغد في ما بعد اذان
المغرب اليوم
واعتقد انه عدم الالتفاف الالتزام بالهن
هو يعني مؤسف جدا وينذر بخطر يعني انه
ستمتد
اطلاق النار وستمتد لاجعال الحرب بما
كارثه امكانيه وكارثه اقتصاديه
ايضا اجتماعيه في السودان كانت هناك جهود
كبيره من القوه السياسيه لتحديات الاطراف
والوصول الى هذه الهدنه كمدخل لوقف اطلاق
النار ولكن اعتقد انه ما زال العامل الثقه
يعني غير موجود بين الطرفين المتصارعين
فاضف الى ذلك يبدو انه ما زال هناك
التحشيد وتحشيد من الذين يريدون اجعل
الحرب في
السودان وجرها الى حرب
شامله هذا
الهدنه التي تم الاتفاق عليها مبدئيا الان
هناك معالج جهود مبزوله للحديد عن كيفيه
هذه الهدنه فيما يتعلق بوقف الدعم
اللوجيسي ووقف التسليح ووقف تحرك الجيوش
نفسه هناك عدم ثقه من الطرفين في هذا
الاتجاه نزعه الان الى يعني
النظر وجعل ضمانات للاطراف المتقاتله
بمساعده
الحلفاء الدوليين والاقليمين فنتمنى ان
تقف هذه الحرب لانه نحن
الثلاثه ايام او اربعه ايام السابقه
القضيه غياب التيار الكهربائي
والمياه هناك يعني كارثه صحيه على الابواب
اضف الى ذلك الخوف من مده هذه الولايات
التي تعاني من هشاشه امنيه وحاله من
الاستقطاب القبلي انك تتحدث عن الهشاشه
على المستوى الصحي والانساني وغير اسمح لي
استاذ ان انتقل الى مدير قوات الدفاع
المدني السوداني الفريق الدكتور عثمان عطى
مصطفى استاذ عثمان يعني مع عدم التزام
الطرفين بالهدنه التي كان يفترض ان تكون
هدنه انسانيه قبل كل شيء بسبب يعني ما
يعانيه اليوم السودانيين مع دخول اليوم
الرابع للمواجهات كيف هي الصوره على الارض
يعني الواقع الانساني ان كان بالمستشفيات
وان كان بالجوانب الاخرى
بدا التحيه لكم والواحد يعني يتاسف
للاحداث الداميه التي شهدتها الدلال منذ
اربع ايام
والتي روعت المواطنين وراح ضحيتها لكم
كريم من المواطنين وقوات المتقاتله انا
اترحم على كل الشهداء وهاجر شفاء للمصابين
يمكن هنالك تاكيد لهذه الحراره في انقطاع
التيار الكهربائي والمياه منعدمه المياه
والمواد الغذائيه
ولكن كل المحلات التجاريه
وتراكم التسجيل في الشوارع دون تدخل
الفوري للاطلاء يعني نسبه للاحداث
واستمرار المعارك مما يجعل التحرك يعني
غير اني
السيد وزير الداخليه رئيس المجلس القومي
للدفاع المدنيه الفريق والسلطه حنان حامد
محمد عمر يعني قرار وزاري رقم 1995
الان الوضع الان الوضع الانساني داخل
شوارع الخرطوم هل يمكن نقل الصوره من هناك
خصوصا وان هناك نقص على مستوى المياه على
مستوى الاغذيه حتى على المستوى الطبي
الوضعي
في ظل يعني تواصل المعارف هنالك صعوبه في
التدخل الفوري لام الجرحى به يعني انتشار
الجسد وستترها
اشكاليه كبيره يعني عقبه بانه بسرعه
المطلوبه
الاليه اللي بتتكون من الدفاع المدني
ووزاره الصحه والصليب الاحمر والهلال
الاحمر والشرطه لا بد انه يفتح لها المجال
عشان تقدر تقدم الخدمات بتاع الطوائم
القانون الدولي الانساني حتى حتى يعني
الصليب الاحمر الدولي والقوات الدوليه
يعني المؤسسات الانسانيه العامله في
المجال الصحي يعني اعلنت بالساعات الماضيه
عن التعرض فريقه للكثير من العمليات
الامنيه من المضايقات وغيرها وبالتالي هل
نتحدث عن وضع انساني كارثه بهذه الاثناء
نتحدث عن وضعي كارثي انسان نحن ذاهبين حسب
الاتفاقيات الدوليه يلتزموا بهذه
الاتفاقيات ويريدوا المجال لخدمات الطوارئ
عشان يقدروا حياه الناس
ويستطيعوا ان يتعاملوا في انتشار الجثث
بسرعه المطلوبه وحقيقه ان احنا كلنا
سواء وكان متحركات او اكياس لحفظ الجسر
ومعدات اخرى ونعمل برضو يعني نجيب يعني
بكل الدول يعني تقديم
برضو في هذا المجال لكي ترجم خدمات طوارئ
متميزه
طب هذه المناشدات التي تناشدونها وايضا
المناشدات التي يناشدها المجتمع الدولي
اليوم لاطراف النزاع لا تلقى اذان صاغيه
يعني هناك مزيد من الضحايا المزيد من
القتلى اذا ما بقي الوضع على ما هو عليه
بالساعات المقبله خصوصا اننا نتحدث عن
هدنه طلب بها الجانب الدولي الجانب
الامريكي تحديدا ولم يلتزم بها الطرفان
اذا ما اكملنا على هذا المنوال كيف تكون
الصوره بالساعات المقبله
سوف تكون الوضع كارثي يعني كل ما كانت
هنالك كنا نستطيع ان نتدخل بسرعه المطلوبه
اتنزل مقدر هل لديك استاذ نور الدين استاذ
هل لديك اي ارقام عن الضحايا عن الجثث
التي لم يتم اجلاء
في
حصرتي يعني حصل الجثث والضحايا
وحدد المصابين وان شاء الله في خلال
الاوقات الجايه نقدر يعني تكون عندنا
احصائيه متكامله
اسمح لي استاذ ان اشير الى ان واشنطن
والامم المتحده بهذه الاثناء تؤكدان عدم
نجاح الهدنه في السودان حتى اللحظه اعود
الى استاذ نور الدين بابا بكر من الخرطوم
الناطق
الرسمي باسم حزب المؤتمر السوداني
والقياده في قوى الحريه والتغيير استاذ
يعني عندما تعلن الان واشنطن والامم
المتحده اللتان كانتا يعني
الراعي الاساسي لهذه الهدنه بان الهدنه لم
تنجح وبالتالي نحن نتحدث عن ان طرفي
النزاع ما زال بعيدين عن الهدنه بعيدين عن
الحوار بعيدين عن اي مخرج سلمي لهذه
الازمه ماذا يعني ذلك
الفتره الماضيه بذلنا مجهود كبير لمحاوله
التهدئه ويعني المضيفي طريق ثالث هو يتعلق
بالحله السياسي وحتى مساله
الدمج الجيوش واصلاحها اعتقد ان الطريقه
الامثل لهذا الطريق هو الحل السياسي
والتفاوض الى فوهه البندقيه والحرب
السودانيين من التحول المدني الديمقراطي
السنين عديده تفيد السودانيين من
الاستقرار والامن تفرض واقع اجتماعي
وسيارته جديد لا منتصر فيه بالتالي نحن
نعتقد الممازال الان هناك فرصه لتحكيم صوت
العقل ما زال هناك فرصه ليضع المتسارعين
من
اللاعبين السلاح جانبا
تحلي بالمسؤوليه
ومعرفه
الاضرار الحرب وما يمكن ان تقلده لسودان
نحن لدينا تجربه تاريخيه في الحروب في
جنوب السودان انتهت بموت اثنين مليون
مواطن سوداني وانفصال جزء حديث من السودان
والان وايضا هناك تخلفت عشرات الالاف من
الضحايا وحرق القرى
ويعني انهيار النتيجه الاجتماعي والدوله
في اداره بالتالي نحن الان لا نريد ان
نقود هذه التجربه مره اخرى ونعتقد انه
الطريق الذي يمكن ان يجنب السودان هذا
الخراب الشامل هو الجلوس في طاوله الحوار
والنقاش ونعتقد انه تكلفه التنازل عن هذا
الصراع وعن
الانتصارات الذات الق اقل من تكلفه يعني
تجنيب
تكلفه هذا الصراع ان كان على مناطق الشمال
ان كان على مناطق الجنوب ان كان على
الاقليم حتى يعني على الدول المجاوره وهو
الهاجز الاساسي اليوم لدول الاوروبيه
والامريكيه ولكن من الجانب الامريكي اليوم
كان هناك اتصال من قبل وزير الخارجيه مع
طرفي النزاع اتحدث عن البرهان وحمايه لوقف
لهذه الهدنه ولوقف اطلاق نار يسمح بتمرين
مساعدات الانسانيه ويكون هناك يعني
نافذه للحوار السياسي او الامم مع الطرفين
من المعلوم بانه كان المفروض ان تفرض
عقوبات على الطرفين في عام 2021 وكان هناك
مشروع قرار بهذا الشان اعيد وجمد بعد
مثولهم الى بعض الشروط الدوليه اليوم في
حال لم يمتثل الطرفان الى الشروط الدوليه
هل ممكن هل تتوقعون اعاده فر ط عقوبات
عليهم
الطريق ايضا يمكن ان يكون طريق خطر على
مستقبل السودان هذا الطريق سيحفز الاطراف
للمضي قدما في مساله الحرب وعدم الجنح انه
الان ما زال يمكن التحكم
ايضا بنفس السياق هناك حديث داخلي وخارجي
عن محاوله استفاده ايضا اطراف خارجيه من
النزاع الدائر داخل السودان في حال طال
امدو هل يعني تتوقعون ان يكون يعني من هو
الطرف طبعا الدولي الذي ممكن ان يستفيد من
هذا الصراع الداخلي
يجعل هناك قوه اقليميه ودوليه كثيره لديها
مطامع في السودان السودان بلد يتمتع به
ثروات
كثيره سواء كانت طبيعيه او معدنيه او
اراضي شات اصالحها للزراعه ايضا يعني تماس
مع دول كثيره السودان يمثل افريقيا ولديه
ايضا يعني علاقات وحدود مع الوطن العربي
بالتاكيد هناك قوه دوليه واقليميه تدعى
لتحقيق مصالحه السودان نحن نعتقد انه
عدم استقرار السودان
يعني جر السودان لهذه
الارض لن ياتي بالخير لهذه الدول
الاقليميه والدوليه انه بالع
[__]
هذا النقطه التي كنت اليها
بان هناك وجهه نظر اخرى بان السودان غير
مستقر وبالتالي السودان خطر على المنطقه
وعلى العالم من باب ملفين الملف الاول هو
موقع السودان الاستراتيجي على البحر
الاحمر وبالتالي الموانئ الموجوده ان كان
على البحر الاحمر وان كان على الحدود
الاثيوبيه مما سيؤثر على حركه التجاره
والملف الثاني وهو موضوع ملف الهجره الذي
يعتبر يعني ملف اساسي للمجتمع الغربي
وبالتالي هل استقرار السودان هو حاجه
يعني للطرفين
[موسيقى]
هو استقلال
لانهيار السودان وانتشار الحرب في بلد فيه
كما ذكرت انتشار واسع للسلاح واستقطاب
وقبلي يمكن ان يهدد ليست وحده فقط بل كل
المحيط الاقليمي ودولي سيهدد الحدود في
الدول المحيطه بالسودان سيكون هناك نزوح
كبير السودان ايضا يعني كما ذكرته هو
بوابه
للنزوح
لاوروبا
والعالم الغربي ايضا التوترات في في
الحدود يمكن
ان
يكون النتائج وخيمه على الاقليم ككل وحتى
على المجتمع الدولي بالتالي اعتقد انه
المدخل الصحيح لهذا لحل هذه الازمه هو انه
يكون هناك اسطول مستقل هناك سودان امن
هناك علاقات جيده مع هذه الدول الاقليميه
والدوليه وتبادل للمنافع يمكنها ان يتحقق
لكل الاطراف اعتقد انه المضي قدما في
تقسيم السودان هذا هذه المساله خطيره على
السودان وخطيره على الدولي هناك تجربه
انتقال جنوب السودان ما زال
هذه الدوله اعتقد انه ما زالت لم تستقر
هناك ما زالت يعني حروب ساعود اليك استاذ
واتحدث عن انفصال جنوب السودان عن المناطق
الاخرى ايضا التي تطالب بالانفصال والحكم
الذاتي والتي ممكن ايضا ان تستفيد في حال
الانفلات الامني ابقى معنا لو سمحت
مشاهدينا وثقت كاميرا العربيه لحظه حدوث
انفجار في محيط مباني القياده العامه
للقوات المسلحه السودانيه في العاصمه
الخرطوم فلنتابع الصور
كشفت مصادر خاصه للعربيه عن تحركات مصريه
اقليميه تشمل دخول مراقبين دوليين للوصول
الى وقف اطلاق نار خلال عيد الفطر وفتح
ايضا ممرات امنه بين مصر والسودان لمده 48
ساعه بنقل المصابين ودخول المساعدات
الانسانيه بالاضافه الى تخصيص لجنه امميه
دوليه لتسهيل دخولها للاشراف طبعا على
كافه الاسرى من الجانبين وايضا تسهيل مهام
بعثات الامم المتحده وبرامج الغذاء
العالمي من خلال تعيين قوه خاصه لتامين
مهامهم داخل الاراضي السودانيه هذا واوضحت
المصادر ان هذه النقاشات تدور حول توقيت
وقف اطلاق النار والانسحاب الى خطوط يتم
الاتفاق عليها هذا وكشفت المصادر ايضا
وجود مشاورات حول تشكيل لجنه دوليه محايده
مسؤوله عن التحقيق في الاحداث الحاليه في
السودان
في الولايات يمكن تمت السيطره عليها تماما
نحن نسيطر الان على القياده العامه
بالكامل مسيطره على مطار الخرطوم لصيفر
على اذا هذا تمرد واضح
القانون العسكري ان هذا تمر بالنسبه
للمبادرات نحن نرحب بكل مبادره لكن الان
المعرفه
كمان المعرفه نحن ليست لدينا مشكله مع
قوات الدعم السريع اثناء نفصل ما بينما
يقوم به محمد حمدان وشقيقي
احداث متسارعه يشهدها السودان في رابع
ايام الاشتباكات الداميه بين الجيش وقوات
الدعم السريع لكن الرؤيه النهائيه بشان
الطرف العسكري الذي سيبسط سيطرته على
الارض لم تتضح حتى هذه اللحظه تعددت
الروايات بين الاطراف المتنازعه والمتضرر
واحد الشعب السوداني الذي عانى وما زال من
هذه الصراعات معدلات القتل والاصابات
تتزايد بوتيره متفاقمه والعديد من
المستشفيات خرجت عن الخدمه فبعضها ضربت
بالقذائف والبعض الاخر انقطعت عنه
الكهرباء ولا يجد للامدادات الطبيه سبيله
اذا استمر القتال سيكون هناك المزيد من
الضحايا الارقام التي حصلت عليها لم يتم
تاكيدها نحن نعتمد على معلومات من الاطباء
السودانيين ومن المستشفيات حتى الان قتل
ما لا يقل عن 185 شخصا واصيب من 1800 شخص
بمن فيهم مدنيون وعناصر الجيش تحرك صعب
يواجه السكان في ظل القصف الجوي
والاشتباكات العنيفه على الارض
واماكن متفرقه احتجز فيها السودانيون منذ
بدايه الاشتباكات ومنها الجامعات غير
المجهزه لحال كهذه والعديد من هؤلاء
المحتجزين حاولوا الخروج للعوده الى
منازلهم اثناء هدنه وقف اطلاق النار التي
دعت اليها بعثه الامم المتحده الا ان
الاطراف المتصارعه لم تلتزم بها رغم
التعهدات باحترامها
نحن حوالي 88
نفر مننا عشرين عامل فيهم كبار السن
وفي حوالي خمسه طالبات المعارك في السودان
احدثت نكسه غذائيه بسبب صعوبه التنقل
وارتفاع الاسعار وسط تعليق العشرات من
برامج المساعدات الانسانيه بعد ان نهبت
الامدادات ودمرت المس
لا يمكنني اعطائك اي ارقام محدده حول قيمه
الممتلكات المسروقه او الامدادات المنهوبه
او حتى المساعدات التي دمرت بسبب القتال
كما قلت في وقت سابق في هذه الظروف لا
يمكن ان يحدث اي توصيل للمساعدات بشكل
اساسي تمديد وقلق اماميان واطراف اقليميه
ودوليه تقف على خط الازمه التي ساحه
الثالثه اكبر بلد افريقي الا ان تلك
المساعي والمحاولات المتعدده لم تجد اذانا
صاغيه حتى الان
سلطان العيبان العربيه
هذا هو قال مسؤول المساعدات بالامم
المتحده مارتن جرافيث ان استهداف موظفين
مساعدات الاغاثيه والمنشات الخاصه بعمليات
الاغاثه في السودان لا يزال مستمره واضاف
في تغريده على تويتر ان الامم المتحده
تتلقى تقارير عن تعرض موظفي الاغاثه
لهجمات واعتداءات واعتبر جريفث هذا غير
مقبول ويجب ان يتوقف مشيرا الى ان مكتب
الامم المتحده للمساعدات في جنوب دارفور
تعرض للنحل
ينضم الينا مشاهدينا في الاستوديو هشام
سلمان الكاتب الباحث والكاتب السياسي
السوداني للحديث طبعا اكثر عن التداعيات
ما يحصل داخل السودان اهلا وسهلا بك استاذ
هاشم او هشام عفوا استاذ يعني اليوم سابدا
من موضوع
المبادره التي طرحت خصوصا من الجانب
المصري ومن جنوب السودان طبعا هناك ملف
الامن القومي للجانب المصري الذي يعتبر
يعني موضوع اساسي بكل الانفلات الحاصل
داخل السودان ولكن ايضا هناك ملفان
اساسيان موضوع سد النهضه مع ما نراه اليوم
من انقطاع للمياه وايضا موضوع البحيرات
ومنطقه البحيرات وامنه بجنوب السودان هل
هذان الطرفان قادران اكثر على يعني الضغط
بموضوع الهدنه ام المجتمع الدولي هو
القادر اكثر الحديث مع الطرفين
شكرا
سلم عليك وحي المشاهدينك انا بفتكر انه
الملف السوداني هو ملف معقد
ومصري من الجهات اللي
لاباع طويل جدا في الملف لكن بتتعامل معه
معامله امنيه بحته
ويمكن ده هو سبب المشكله يعني يعني حتى
انه السودان يعني وضع الاحتراف
الدبلوماسيين المصريين يعني انه السودان
ما عنده مكتب حتى في وزاره الخارجيه
المصريه مكتوب في جهاز الامن والمخابرات
وهنا التعامل الامني البحث ده دايما ما
بينتج حلول لانه الحلول الامنيه معروفه
شكلها كيف
السودان في حاجه لحلول دبلوماسيه من يمكن
ان يفرض اليوم يعني حتى الجانب الامريكي
يستعمل اليوم عصا العقوبات من جديد على
الطرفين لفرض حل الجانب الامم يتحدث عن
الجانب الانساني اكثر من مبادره سياسيه
بحته الجانب الاوروبي حتى الساعه يعني
مناشدات للطرفين هو انا بفتكر يمكن في
نقطه كانت
برضو تكلمنا عنها الجانب الاممي عنده باور
كبير جدا ممكن يستخدمه في السودان واحد
اثنين الجانب المهيم جدا
وين المجتمع المدني والساسه السودانيين
المفروض يكون هم اصحاب مبادرات لانه
المفروض يقدموا حلول ما هم الضلع الثالث
الضلع ده غايب يعني انا بفتكر انه
السياسيين في السودان المفروض يطلعوا
المبادره
تلزم كل العسكريين
زي ما كان مثلا ولكن عندما نتحدث عن صراع
عسكر صراع نفوذ وسلطه فقط هل سيستمعون الى
الجانب الداخلي ما هم لم يستمعوا اصلا
خلال الحوار وخلال المؤتمر بطيئه الاشهر
والسنوات الماضيه
معلش انا بختلف السودان وضع مختلف يا
جماعه كيف السودان المجتمع المدني اقوى من
الدوله اقوى من اقوى من قوه الشعب اتحدث
عن قوه الشعب فانت في ايدك تستخدمها انت
كساسي
وكمجتمع مدني عندك القوه الرئيسيه عندما
تقعد متفرج هذا ما كنا نتحدث عنه بالساعات
الاولى دور الشعب السوداني اليوم بوضع حد
لهذا الصراع على الارض كيف يمكن ان يلعب
هذا الدور والادوار دي المفروض هي محتاجه
تفكير خارج الصندوق لكن انا بفتكر انه
الاحزاب السياسيه عندها الكثير اللي
تلعبوا المفروض يكون هي تستلم زمام
المبادره استلامه لزمام المبادره حتقدر
تستطيع انها تقدم فعلا حلول وتنتج حلول ما
هي الحلول ما بتجي بانتظار الاحداث في فرق
بين تصنع الاحداث
وتتفرج على الاحداث
انا بفتكر انه نحن في حوجه ليساسه يصنعوا
الاحداث
وخاصه انهم عندهم العصر الغليظه عصا الشعب
عصا الشعب والشعب خصوصا ان الاوضاع اليوم
تتدهور انسانيا واقتصاديا مما يعني سيشكل
حافز اكثر للشعب لان ينزل مجددا الى
الشارع ابقى معي استاذ لو سمحت دعنا ننتقل
الى مدينه مروي ومراسل العربيه نزار
بقداوي قبل ذلك دعونا مشاهدينا نستمع الى
الاشتباكات التي عادت على ما يبدو بمحيط
القياده العامه داخل الخرطوم
اعد الى الزميل اللي زار بقداوي مراسل
العربيه في مدينه مروي نزار داخل الخرطوم
حتى الساعه لا التزام بالهدنه المعلنه كيف
هي الصوره من مروي
مروي تختلف كثيرا عن بقيه مدن السودان
سواء كان في مدينه الفاشر التي همت فيها
الامور عصر هذا اليوم وافادت مصادر
للعربيه والحدث بان الاوضاع في مدينه
الفاشر قد انفرط فيها عقد الامن
خرقا لما حدث والتمتع عليه في الهدنه حتى
في الخرطومه الامور كانت مغايره لكن هنا
في شمال السودان في مدينه مروي الامور
تختلف لان الجيش السوداني بحسب
تصريحاته قد اجبر القوات التي كانت تتمركز
في قاعده مروي وفي المطار بمغادره هذه
المنطقه التي وصلت اليها قبل يومين
دعم السريع من من المطار ومن مدينه مروي
هل يعني رصدتم صحه هذا الكلام هل فعلا كان
هناك انسحاب لعدد كبير من قوات الدعم
السريع
نعم ذكروا لنا بان من سيارات الدعم السريع
اتجهت جنوبا نحو مئه كيلومتر من قاعده
مروي العسكريه الجويه
وبعدها مباشره ايضا اكدت لنا المعلومات ان
الطيران الحربي تعامل مع هذه السيارات
واجبرها الى ان تتفرق في مناطق مختلفه في
مناطق زراعيه في الشوارع متفرعه غير
الطريقه الرئيس الذي كانت تسلكه هذه
السيارات الاوضاع الان هادئه الحديث عن
الهدنه يبدو انه
لا يجد مجالا للتطبيق من واقع انه لا
اشتباكات الان هنالك حاله من الهدوء الحذر
تسود قاعده مروي تسود ايضا مدينه مروي هذه
المدينه التي تتابع كل لحظات هذه العمليه
العسكريه التي بدات قبل اربعه ايام وما
زال صباها يتردد هنا في هذه المحليه
وبالتالي هل نتحدث عن هدوء حذر بمدينه
مالاوي
اكيد الهدوء الحذر هو سيد الموقف لان
حاله الالتباس وحاله الاشتباك التي كانت
خلال الايام الماضيه التمركز واعاده
الانتشار ليس من حديث قطعي عن خروج كل
القوه التي كانت هنا من قبل قوات الدعم
السريع من هذه المحليه من هذه الولايه
خروجا كاملا حتى نؤكد ونقول بان قوات
الدعم السريعه الان خارج حدود محليه مروي
سواء في الجانب الشرقي او في الجانب
الغربي او في اليوم بعد الحديث عن انسحاب
نرصد مجددا العوده وخصوصا خلال ساعات
الليل وبالتالي هو انسحاب تكتيكي اعاده
تجميع والعوده مجددا الى محيط المطار لان
يعني الصراع على النقاط الاساسيه مازال
مستمر
نزال على ما يبدو
اسمح لي سنستمع الى اصوات الانفجارات
والمواجهات بالخرطوم
اذا مشاهدينا عوده يعني اصوات الاشتباك
المتقطعه التي تعود بين الحين والاخر
بوتيره اقل طبعا بعد الهدنه التي اعلن
عنها مع بدء ساعات الليل اليوم التي من
المتوقع كان ان تستمر 24 ساعه حتى الساعه
لا التزام كامل بهذه الهدنه نتحدث عن هدنه
متقطعه يتم خرق بين الوقت والاخر طبعا هذه
الصور الخاصه بقناه العربيه بمحيط القياده
العامه للجيش السوداني طبعا كما نشاهد
بالصوره هي
يعني صوره
ظلمه تماما وسوداء تماما وذلك بسبب انقطاع
التيار الكهربائي بهذه المنطقه بعد
المواجهات التي دارت بين الطرفين بالساعات
الماضيه كانت التيار الكهربائي قد عاد الا
انه انقطع مجددا بسبب حده الاشتباك بين
الطرفين انقطاع لا ينحصر فقط بالكهرباء
انما ينسحب ايضا على المياه على المواد
الغذائيه على مواد الاستشفاء وايضا على
الحاله الانسانيه التي يعاني منها سكان
العاصمه الخرطوم وسكان المناطق التي ينحصر
فيها الصراع بين كل من قوات الدعم السريع
والجيش السوداني اعود مشاهدينا الى ضيفي
باستوديو استاذ يعني اليوم بعض التقارير
التقارير الجديه
بالفترات الماضيه كانت تتحدث اتحدث عن
تقارير صنع القرار بالغرب تتحدث عن ان
يعني وتيره تصاعد نفوذ العسكر داخل
السودان تنذر بمواجهه حتميه بين الطرفين
على السلطه ومن هنا يجب ربط المساعدات
بالمساعدات الانسانيه
بالجانب المدني وتثبيت اكثر للوجود المدني
ما كانوا يعلمون بانهم ذاهبين وسيصلون الى
صراع لماذا انتظروا حتى هذه اللحظه والله
انا بفتكر السؤال وجيه فعلا هو
الغرب يعني كان راعي اتفاقا اللي هو
الاتفاق الاطاري انا بفتكر انه الاتفاق
الايطالي بغض النظر في ناس بيقولوا اتفاق
الاطار هو سبب المشكله
كان ممكن تطوير لو الناس ما عاجبك خاصه
بالنسبه للعساكر او بالنسبه للنظاميين او
العسكريين كانوا يريدون حل كان ممكن
تطويره كان ممكن يطوروها او هي بالعكس هي
وجدت ما هو في النهايه الحل الا اذا كان
هم عندهم حاجه ثانيه لكن الحل هو في دمج
القوات وتكوين جيش قومي واحد
والخروج من الحياه السياسيه والاقتصاديه
ده حل لا مفر منه لو قامت حرب لو الحرب
استمرت 100 سنه ده مطلب الشعب السوداني
الشعب السوداني يعلم تبارك الشعب السوداني
يا جماعه عنده اجنده واضحه اجنده الوطنيه
على راسها التغيير التغيير هدفه سقفي
بتاعه هو الانتقال المدني الديمقراطي
شاء العسكري ام
ابو
فبالتالي لا بد من الوصول
للسقف اللي هو الانتقال المدني الديمقراطي
والادوات بتاعته الاداه سلميه السوداني لو
اصلا كان بيفكر بطريقه ما طبيعيه او
بطريقه عسكريه كان ازال البشير بالسلاح في
ناس شالوا حركات الكفاح المسلح لكن الشعب
السوداني
اتخذ السلميه خيار هم مفروض وهو يريد
الانتقال السلمي للسلطه بدون بدون هدر دم
وبدون الحاصل تقدم المجتمع المدني معه هل
على طبق من ذهب وهم لا يريدون طبعا استاذ
اسمح لي ان انتقل الى الخرطوم وينضم الينا
الدكتور الرشيد ابراهيم رئيس قسم العلوم
السياسيه بمركز العلاقات الدوليه
والدبلوماسيه في الخرطوم استاذ اليوم يعني
هناك
عنوانين اساسيين لا التزام بالهدنه
وبالتالي لا فتح لقنوات الحوار لا حل
سياسي يعني
الخيار الاخر وهو الانفلات الامني
الانفلات السياسي داخل السودان الانفلات
يعني تهديد دول الجوار ويعني التهديد
مستقبل سودان موحد كيف تنظرون الى هذا
الموضوع
نعم فيما يلي
خرق الهدنه التي تم التوصل اليها اليوم
منذ ساعه السادسه حتى السادسه من مساء
الغد واضح يعني اذا ربطنا
حديث او احاطت السيد
رئيس البيع ساعه الدوليه لمجلس الامن
وحينما اتحدث بنص واضح بان قياده الدعم
السريع ليس لديها قدره على ايصال
التعليمات لافرادها لانها فقدت الاتصال
هذا يعني عمليا عدم امكانيه تنفيذ هذه
الهدنه بالاضافه للعوامل الاخرى التي
تتعلق بالثقه كما ان واضح انه هنالك فوارق
في
الحضور
والكثافه الميدانيه وبالتالي ربما تعمل
الاطراف على تحسين الموقف العسكري على
الميدان حتى تحسن موقفها التفاوض هذا ايضا
يطفي على عمليه عدم الالتزام اسباب
موضوعيه واسباب جوهريه
اصلا بدون يعني ان يقوم فريق بتصفيه الاخر
نعم نحن في التحليل لا نخاطب النوايا ولا
نحاكم النوايا بغدر ما نتناول الوقائع على
الارض ولذلك انا استعنت بحديث فوق كلر في
ان القوات الدعم السريع فقط تسيطره على
قواتها وهذا حديث
موثق يمكن ان نعتمد عليه في نقد العمليه
والان العمليه في بداياتها يعني ان تعسرت
اليوم يمكن ان تنجح غدا ولكن بالضروره جدا
ان نخاطب مناطق القصور وان نتحاشاها وان
يكون هنالك سعيد لانه ليس هنالك خيار اخر
عمليات تحسين الموقف ايضا العسكري افتكر
انها برضو ستكون عقبه كبيره
انقطاع التواصل بين القيادات والارض يعني
يعني انفلات امني الانفلات الامني يعني
عدم القدره على تطبيق هدنه عدم القدره على
تطبيق هدنه يعني ايضا عدم القدره على فتح
قنوات تواصل وحوار بين الطرفين وهي يعني
سلسله متكامله اليوم كلها تؤدي الى مكان
واحد هو واقع ماساوي ويعني قاتم للداخل
السوداني خصوصا مع واقع
معيشه وواقع انساني صعب جدا من هذه
الناحيه اذا ما استمر الوضع والصوره على
ما هي ماذا تعني على الواقع السوداني وعلى
السوداني
نعم انا لا اتوقع اني استمر الحال وان
تمضي الامور نحو الحاجه التدحرج السريع من
واقع ان اننا الان لدينا دوله قائمه
الدوله السودانيه لم تنهار ومؤسساتها لم
تنهار وان حدث بها شرخ كما ذكرت القوات
المسلحه هي موجوده وهي ضامنه والان هي
تعمل على القيام بواجباتها التي نص عليها
القانون في بسط الامن وفي الاطلاع بمهابها
والان هي موجوده في الميدان والعلي اشير
الى البيانات التطمينيه التي تصدر من
قياده
الناطق الرسمي باسم القوات المسلحه العميد
نبيل عبد الله فيما يلي ان التقديرات
السياسيه ايضا هي تستصحب ان التاخير في
حسم هذه المعركه او انهاء حاله الصراحه
هذه له تاثيراته على المواطن انا احسها
كمواطن والان موجود في الخرطوم لا اجد ماء
حتى للوضوء يعني هذه حقائق الان الصور
والتقارير تتحدث عن خروج بعض المرافق
الصحيه يعني هذه ايضا
حقائق على الارض لا يمكن انكارها ولكن يجب
التعامل معها والتفكير جديا في كيفيه
معالجتها بالطرق الصحيحه واظن انه ذلك
اجراءات قد تمت في هذا الصدد يعني وزاره
الداخليه اليوم اصدرت اصدرت امرا بتكوين
لجنه وطنيه
بالتضامن مع التزام اشير لهذا العاجل الذي
ياتي يعني بصلب ما كنا نتحدث عنه من ان لا
هدنه على الارض وبالتالي لا هدنه بالسياسه
المخابرات العامه السودانيه تقول نؤكد ان
لا حوار ولا تفاوض مع قياده الدعم السريع
شكرا لك استاذ هنا ايضا اشير بان مجموعه
الدول الصناعيه السبع ادانت الاشتباكات
بين الجيش وقوات الدعم السريع في السودان
واعتبرت المجموعه في بيان ان الاشتباكات
تهدد امن وسلامه المدنيين وايضا تزعزع
المساعي الى المسار الديمقراطي ودعت
المجموعه الدول الصناعيه السبع كل الاطراف
لوقف العنف فورا وبدون شروط مسبقه والعوده
طبعا الى التفاوض واتخاذ الخطوات الضروريه
لتراجع التوتر وضمان سلامه المدنيين جميعا
بما فيهم الطواقم الدبلوماسيه والمؤسسات
الانسانيه
وفي ذات السياق اكد وزير الخارجيه المصري
سامح شكري ان بلاده ستكثف الاتصالات مع
الاطراف السودانيه المتنازعه من اجل
استئناف الحوار السلمي لتسويه الوضع
بينهما وجدد شكري التاكيد ايضا على ضروره
ان يمتنع جميع اصحاب المصلحه والنفوذ
الاجانب عن تصعيد الوضع في السودان معبرا
عن امله في التوصل الى حل قريب بين الجيش
وقوات الدعم السريعه
اعود مشاهدينا اضافه بالاستوديو الاستاذ
هشام سلمان الكاتب والباحث السياسي استاذ
يعني داخل السودان كان هناك معارك كثيره
خاضها الجيش عبر يعني التاريخ السوداني
اخر عمليه انفصال حصلت عام 2011 لجنوب
السودان اليوم هناك نتحدث عن شمال السودان
الجزء الشمالي والشرقي هو ايضا يطالب
بكيادات نتحدث ايضا عن اقاليم اخرى تطالب
بكيان ذاتي اذا ما بقي الوضع على حاله
وكان هناك يعني تعنت من قبل طرفي النزاع
ودخلت البلاد بحاله الانفلات الكامل ماذا
يعني ذلك على واقع السودان كمنطقه التي
اصبحت تتاكل وعلى دول الجوار
والله لا غدر ابنه يحصل كده لكن طبعا هو
في حاله
السيناريو الغير طبيعي هو الاثر ما على
السودان ليس السودان لوحده
نحن بنتوقع المنطقه كلها السودان
بغض النظر هذا الامتداد الجغرافي والموقع
بتاعه والامتدادات سواء كان في غرب الغره
دول الساحل كلها
افريقي جنوب الصحراء لحد لما تصل الى
الامتداد كده لحد مالي والنيجر وحدة شمال
نيجيري المنطقه دي اصلا هي اصلا منطقه ما
مستغره
دور كبير جدا في استقرار السودان
السودان عنده ثلاثه محاور ثلاثه ده محور
بالعكس اربعه كمان المحور الثاني اللي هو
دول القرن الافريقي اذا اثيوبيا وريتريا
وجيبوتي والصومال ودي اي انفلات امنيه او
سيؤثر على امتداد هذه
البحيرات برضو
جنب السوداني
المناطق دي كلها مناطق هشه بتتاثر
بالسودان تاثير مبالغ فيه بالاضافه الى
الجار الشماليه اللي هي مصر انا بفتكر انه
العالم كلها يجب ان يعمل على
السودان ده يتحط في مساره صحيح لانه اي
امتلات في السودان يعني
شكرا لك استاذ هشام سلمان الكاتب والباحث
السياسي على وجودك معنا داخل الاستوديو
شكرا جزيلا وشكرا لمشاهدين
مشاهدينا الى هنا اتي الى ختام هذه الساعه
طبعا تغطيه العربيه مستمره للتداعيات
ولنقل الصوره من داخل السودان والان الى
الزملاء راويه وطاهر
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات